欢迎回来，希望学习柯里化 元组和函数类型给你带来了乐趣
我们现在要讲的是类型类（type class）和多态（polymorphic）函数
多态函数不是用具体类型定义的 而是用类型变量（type variable）定义的
下面是一个十分多态的多态函数例子
length 函数 想要计算一个列表的长度
不需要知道列表元素的类型
列表 [1, 2, 3] 和列表 ['a', 'b', 'c'] 的长度都是 3
计算列表的长度时 元素的类型无关紧要
这里 length 的类型是
[a] -> Int 其中 a 在 Haskell 中称作类型变量
以大写字母开头的类型是具体类型 比如 Int 的 I 大写了
a 以小写字母开头 因此是类型变量
意思是对于任意类型 a length 的类型是 a 的列表到整数
如果你习惯使用 Java 和 C# 的泛型（generic） 类型变量一般是在函数类型中显式声明的
比如在 C# 中会定义类型 t 的 length 函数（length<t>）
参数是 t 的列表 返回值是一个整数
但在 Haskell  中 a 是类型变量 因此被隐式限定了
不需要加尖括号之类的
Haskell 在这方面有优势
但代价就是类型变量需要以小写字母开头 类型以大写字母
这里的类型是 对于任意类型 a length 接受一个 a 的列表
返回一个整数 和你想的一样
并且和列表元素的类型没有关系
你只关心元素有多少 不关心是什么
在 length [False True] 中 a 的类型是 Bool 长度是 2
这里则是整数的列表 因此 a 的类型是 Int
长度是 4
两个例子中都使用了 length 的类型是 对于任意 a [a] -> Int
第一种情况 a 是 Bool 第二种是 Int
为了不显式声明 length 的哪个类型是多态的
Haskell 就得对类型和类型变量的名字空间进行区分
类型变量必须以小写字母开头
习惯上用 a b c 等等表示类型变量
在 Java 和 C# 这类语言中 习惯上使用 S T R 表示类型变量
Haskell 中是小写的 a b c C# 中会写 List<T> 而 Haskell 中是 [a].
接下来是一些 Haskell 标准 Prelude （序幕）中的多态函数
标准 Prelude 库相当于 Haskell 版的 SDK （Java 标准库）或者 BCL （C# 标准库）
和每种语言都带有的标准库一样
函数的类型揭示了很多实现相关的信息
看第一个
fst 接收类型为 (a, b) 的元组 返回类型 a 的值
这个函数能做什么呢
它接收一个元组 返回 a 类型的值
因此从类型中可以很明显看出功能 返回元组第一个元素
现在看 head 函数的类型 对任意类型 a 接收一个 a 的列表 返回一个 a 类型的值
这种情况下有很多选择 给定一个 a 类型的列表
如果需要返回一个 a 类型的值的话 可以挑选表里任意一个元素 head 返回第一个元素
有趣的事情是 在空表上使用 head 会发生什么
这种情况下会返回 undefined 或者抛出异常（exception）
这没有在类型中给出 类型说的是对于任意类型 a 的列表函数将返回 a 类型的值
但这并不是完全正确的 因为给定空表
它会失败 并且无法返回一个值
第三个函数 接收一个整数返回一个函数 返回的函数接收一个列表并返回一个列表
记住 带箭头的类型中 结合性是向右的
如果加上括号的话 应该是 Int -> ([a] -> [a])
take 接收一个数 再接收一个列表 取出前 n 个元素 作为返回的列表
下面的 zip 函数接收两个列表 返回一个元素对列表
它工作的方式是别收两个列表 分别将其元素结对
当不用柯里化时 zip 的类型更清晰一点
它的类型成了 ([a], [b]) -> [(a, b)]
从中可以看出 zip 将两个列表扭到一起了
最后一个函数可能时 Haskell 中最简单的函数了 恒等函数 id
对于任意类型 a 它接收一个 a 类型的值 返回一个 a 类型的值
稍加思考就会发现 这个函数只能直接返回参数值
否则很难对任意类型 a 进行处理
恒等函数 id 也就是对任意 a : a -> a 它能做的唯一事情就是立刻返回参数
如果你对观察类型就可以得到实现方面的信息这件事很感兴趣的话
可以读 Philip Wadler 的论文 Theorems for Free （免费定理）
论文中会解释 每一个多态类型 都会给出一个对该函数成立的定理
这一话题深入 如果想要读的话 课程网站上会有到那篇论文的链接
最后一个函数相关的话题是重载（overload）
函数重载应该众所周知了 很多语言都支持
比如 Java 中可以使用不同的参数类型重载函数
我可以定义函数 foo 接收一个整数
接下来可以重载它让它接受布尔值
还可以让它重载接收一个列表
注意到函数的名字不变 但参数的类型不同
但在 Haskell 中 重载的形式有所不同
它对应于面向对象编程语言中的接口（interface）
在 Haskell 中重载函数的意思和面向对象中的重载完全不同
它的意思是限制参数的类型 比如要对列表求和的话
不能将 sum 的类型写成 [a] -> a 因为假如是字符的列表就不能求和了
也许你会说可以定义对字符的求和 但对元组列表进行求和呢
这种情况下 对 (a, b) 类型的列表的和 不应该返回 (a, b) 这很不合理
我们想要的是将列表元素的类型限制在能求和的类型上
这就是 Haskell 重载的用处
sum 的类型是 Num a => [a] -> a
意思是 sum 并不是接收任何类型 a 的列表
而只接受类型类 Num 中的类型 a
如果用面向对象的说法的话 就是实现了 Num 接口的类型 a 的列表
记号是 Num a =>
如果你是 Java C# PHP 或者 C++ 程序员的话
你可以把它想象成限制函数可以使用的值
Java 中可以做同样的事 对一个泛型函数可以限制参数需要实现特定的接口
C# 和大多数语言中都可以 Haskell 也不例外
sum 接收一个列表 返回一个值 但只有当列表中的值支持 Num 类型类 或者说 Num 接口时才可以做到
这个例子是整数上的 sum 这里 a 是 Int
我们知道整数是数
因此没有问题 之后会看到 Num 类型类到底是什么
基本上就是可以做加法和乘法等等
第二个例子是浮点数列表的求和
同样也可以进行
最后一个例子中会出现类型错误
因为给定的是字符的列表
而字符不支持 Num 接口
用 Haskell 的话来说就是 字符类型不在 Num 类型类中
除了 Num 以外 Haskell 还有很多类型类 也可以自定义类型类
之后会看到如何定义
这里 Num 类型类表明这一类型支持加法
意味着加法的类型是
接收一个 a 类型的值 返回一个函数 它接收另一个 a 类型的值 最终返回 a 类型的值
但并不是对所有类型 a 都可以
而仅仅是 Num 类型类中的类型
当想要比较两个值是否相等时 它们需要在 Eq 类型类中
可以看到等号操作符的类型是 Eq a => a -> a -> Bool
最后是可以比较大小的值
也就是有序关系的类型 小于操作符的类型是 Ord a => a -> a -> Bool
这里是一些练习 你可以在课程网站上完成 我不会现在给出答案
但我会带你先看看这些练习
第一个问题是 一个由 a b c 三个字符组成的列表 其类型是什么
等等等等
请完成这些练习 因为它们会确保你理解了课程中的概念
还有一些比较复杂的练习
其中没有具体的值 需要计算得到类型
也就是给定一个函数 计算函数的类型
有一个技巧 也就是我想告诉你的秘密
可以使用 GHCi 来检查你的答案 做练习时不用一个一个尝试
你可以打开 GHCi 使用 :type 命令完成练习
就能确保完全正确了
祝你 Hacking 愉快 用 GHCi 来做练习 如果你不用 Haskell 而是其他语言的话 也记得用编译器检查类型
因为我们人类不应该做类型检查
那是应该由计算机来帮我们做的
十分感谢 下周再见